I was looking for one condemnation new
animals we were at the Texas State
Democratic convention taping a fourth of
July theme changed my mind to be
released on July 2nd when noticed a
familiar face its fire bomb lady that's
the girl who posted our location in
Austin precisely and called for people
to firebomb our car and then double down
with a second post for additional
domestic terrorism context so I decided
to confront her hey kid
how are you today quick question for you
why would you encourage people to
firebomb my van why would you do that do
you think that's appropriate to
encourage people to firebomb my van and
hurt my crew when we're just expressing
a difference of opinion why would you
threaten the firebomb my van or
encourage other people to do it at first
she just deny deny deny
good thing we brought a bristol board
there's a matter of fact we have your
pictures right here of your tweets of
you posting our location right now let's
follow told that from either knock AJ so
is it the way you deal with civil
disagreements I've heard a lot of people
talk about calls to civility with
President Trump and conservatives but
what about this what about firebombing
someone committing acts of violence I
would never encourage acts of violence
against you I don't want anyone to ever
hurt you nothing huh this is the
tolerant left no my feelings aren't
writers don't want to be firebomb really
have a place in today's political
discussion wouldn't you say
why the I role you think it does have a
play a role as long as it's a right
target really no opinion in this cell
what if a conservative what if Donald
Trump would encourage anyone to firebomb
somebody else well we're not in war
where does having discussion as we just
did with three or four Democrats and a
man did he say that when did he say that
but I didn't say that but I've never
said do you condemn that no I think it's
great you think it's right so you're
cool with fire bombing people who've
never committed an act of violence this
doesn't bother you you're okay with
encouraging violence against people
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what bothers me is encouraging acts of
violence and acting like an animal
you're the one who started to change
you started to change yes what's the
solution non-violent speech you animals
- looking for one condemnation anyone to
have an opinion on encouraging acts of
violence I discourage them across the
board see her face everywhere and trying
to get people to hard work asking people
to bomb my van bomb Ram fire take care
of it this was clearly an exercise in
futility so they brought out the heavy
artillery strong with the mob eunbi
of course not do you believe it did all
people regardless of their race should
have equal opportunities in this country
absolutely nothing to say just an
apology would be nice you are a coward
we're how artists thank you you're a
coward
have no problem saying you're all calm
and then of course they called the
brutal fascist racist police who agreed
with us that they were dicks look see
this lady encouraged acts of violence
against me and so I just was asking her
why that seems pretty reprehensible
right to post my location and our man
and a bomb saying take care of it that's
pretty bad is confronting a lady who
encouraged firebombing against my car
and asked her why she did but they had
to ask us to leave anyway which we did
unfortunately there still seem to be
some miscommunications it seems they're
less offended by the Nazism than by the
fact that we had a better boost than
them we could just forgot to check the
floor plans oh well as you can see on
this channel my first choice is civil
discourse but when you call people to
acts of violence know this I will find
you I will confront you and I will shame
you hey if you like this video watch one
of these other videos playing in a box
next to me I tell you subscribe
that's all used to say at one point then
we said hit the notification bail
because subscriptions didn't work then
we said bookmark the page but I don't
think that's gonna work if you're using
Google Chrome so join it ladder with
credit calm slash mug Club it's 69 a
year if your student veteran or military
and you get to watch the full daily show
and don't be screwed by notifications or
subscriptions